[Music]
in Walmart people New York oh I love
Walmart people submitted by aliens in
your yard
yep a woman in her adult son so we're
we're saying it a woman in her adult son
were arrested after causing a scene at
Walmart they were kissing each other Oh
have to see what is it with the incest
today Yeah right
is it right no oh they were naked so
this woman her son and a dog named Bo
who caused a scene in a Wisconsin
Walmart so what they're saying is that
cops responded to the Walmart for
reports of a theft when they arrived the
officers found 46 year old named Lisa
screaming at the stores entryway trying
to catch her dog Bo and then while she
was in the front of the store her 25
year old son named Benny was naked
oh yes and exposing himself to customers
in the clothing section of the store
what the [ __ ] you like my shirt is he a
little is he a little he sounds like a
little horny to me yeah so then while Bo
the dog ran up to customers the mom
started erratically pulling apart the
store displays and placing them in her
cart bath salts yeah PCP so then that's
when she was asked to leave by the store
employees but then she was ended up like
she headed to the parking lot to perform
karate moves
I felt like Joe's type of people yeah so
Bo's the unleash and loosed unleashed
and loosed on it in the store uh ya know
grabbing a box of muffin mix attempted
to leave the store the dog tried to
steal yeah damn did you see a power go
up on a shelf oh so then they arrested
the mom in a parking lot all these
people are trash
yeah any a little dog
so they arrested the mom in the parking
lot and but said that she did fight with
the officers and attempted to kick out a
window
Oh like in the comic she really had
karate skills that would be so hilarious
yes she's actually a superhero oh my god
she paused her day to do some karate got
a prat watch told me like she
frantically destroyed a store display
and then was asked to leave it in the
parking lot she's like wait I got a
practice teach you it up in Malibu how
to do Tai Chi and we have it but I
forgot it's supposed to calm you down
that's pretty [ __ ] up the whole time
South okay
I loved me so but I don't go to
Coachella so it's like we're cool are
you talking about ecstasy pills or
prescription pills prescription girl you
know that's the number one killer for
not obvious that's the number one killer
for Caucasians oh I believe it yeah
what's up Enzo what's a benzo is like an
anti-anxiety medicine so like xanax
klonopin out of n is it opioid no okay
but that's the oh that's another one
that's a that's a bad one
anyways enough about me but I'm familiar
with this word good oh you are accepted
here we don't worse okay love it not me
prove it in a different way like you
like like put his spell on like oh yeah
I robbed a bank so as they were as they
were arresting her in the parking lot
that's in there went to go arrest her
son you sure got her son first what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah he's disgusting so then
they're saying that he began to take
clothing off the racks but had no
intention of purchasing
that's important to cover his dick be
like he was close and then hold the
clothes down I don't know because they
they made sure to say that it was an
adult son that's why I'm like maybe he
was like pulling it down to try and
block the cops room
you know they do that in the movies they
like knock over a shelf and like Mack
yeah you can't get me maybe
so then he refused to stop and he had
attempted to run over an officer with
his scooter when the [ __ ] the scooter
comings away he has a scooter parked
inside the wall like a Mad Libs like
someone filled in the blanks like and
then she did karate moves he ran over
the officer with his scooter I'm praying
this isn't in Florida it was constant I
think I got a pass this time
this constant they finally though they
finally got his scooter to stop and then
arrested him and he was arrested for
disorderly called hard is it to stop a
scooter aren't they well I'm thinking
razor scooter am I wrong no I think it's
the Walmart scooters it was like
electric ones for the disabled people
that should go I feel like he could do
me like sweet walking and biking to get
the officers like
yeah and it'll like talking funny though
the police had to include this that the
dog was not charged sitting in jail no
any better I don't like you I don't like
it that's discrimination and Gary was
stealing he should suffer the
consequence is it a little orange
jumpsuit at the dog pound Thursday night
he was taken to Humane Association all
that's said that's like the dog jail did
you should him a warning for the theft
they sued the dog awardee I'm sure he
took it well can we get a mug shot no
damn does Mari is mama box his mom's a
witch Disney so she was a new karate
move she was to expel the 4625 Wow
his mom is 40 see ya
she took the elixir of [ __ ] degrading
her parade craft when you put a spell on
someone you get it back on you times
three oh yeah why would anyone ever put
a spell on it oh well cause if you
really wanted to get somebody it's like
it's worth it to you oh that seems like
a bad premise for a show yeah well it's
not that they didn't make the rules they
just play by them oh yeah she looks like
she's 70 Ross do you think there was
method is he sick well how do you think
she got those I think she was a karate
master yeah she's she's fighting you
know once their drugs and alcohol
evolved you don't mention it he didn't
test them I would love if they were
actually sober yeah and did all this cuz
right now it's like oh they were on
drugs obviously clearly why don't they
what if they were well the sun's I like
the pupils do look a little like hers
are very very tiny what if they went to
a hypnotist show and never got unhip
yeah he just thinks he's like a pool
party and he's taking off his clothes
and stuff and she thinks she's about to
compete you know he's taking his clothes
off had a pool party he's still new
semester what kind of dog was shaggy
Terriers I bet the ones that look
homeless man look like or they look like
they've been electrocuted a little bit
yeah which ones there's a little shaggy
dog homeless I know what you're talking
about ones with the eye you can't see
the eyes cuz it's like looks kind of
like I was thinking like lady in the
[ __ ] with that book transgender you
might Steve's sister has a dog like the
one you're talking about Oh her name is
Lady how cute I like the name lady maybe
I have a picture I love like I have
pictures of people throw a good dog
shame I think you just like looking at
pictures oh I'm a simple girl okay well
are the boys it's kind of homeless no
but he looks okay he looks like he's
wealthier yeah dirtier dirtier fuzzier I
want to know what kind of dog it was I
feel like that would really change the
story let's just say pitbull I worked at
a Humane Society for two weeks and ended
up with two cats I would be the same age
as I couldn't emotional yes my leader my
were they gonna be put down that's why
one was like oh this one has diarrhea we
got to put it down and I was like
diarrhea cuz it like costs more than
like 100 bucks to fix and they're like
we can't wait why don't you just wait
like when the humans get diarrhea just
wait it out and it goes away
I don't know is it the same for cats I
don't know how about dogs guys I'm okay
both you know Larry and Leo I got
pictures let's look at look at them okay
oh you want to see my dog oh okay this
is the mangy Ameche dog Oh
show the camera no he's not very cute
improvising he's cute yeah that's a dog
for we love him
like a homeless piece of crap there's
Toby he looks like an Ewok
[Music]
[Music]